21 cantons c'est le découpage électoral
dans les yvelines pour les élections
départementales pensé lors du
redécoupage dès 2014 le nombre de
cantons dans un département comptant
plus de 500000 habitants ne peut être
inférieure à 17 avec près d'un million
cinq cent mille habitants
les yvelines sont donc passés de 39 à 21
cantons dès le scrutin de 2015
un peu d'histoire les limites des
cantons ont été tracées en 1801 le
redécoupage de 2014 c'est le fruit d'une
volonté gouvernementale de tenir compte
des évolutions démographiques et les
nouvelles délimitations s'appuie sur les
chiffres de l'insee de 2013 alors
comment sont répartis les commune
yvelinoise chaque canton doit désormais
regroupé le même nombre d'habitants avec
une marge de plus ou moins 20 %
explications un million cinq cent mille
habitants / 21 cantons cela nous donne
une moyenne de 71 mille habitants + 1 %
nous amène à 85 mille habitants c'est le
cas de sartrouville le canton le plus
peuplé des yvelines avec 83 mille
habitants -20% cette fois ça nous donne
56 1800 habitants dans les yvelines
c'est le cas du canton de limoux qui est
composé de 57 mille habitants alors pour
respecter cette répartition la
composition des cantons peut sembler un
peu disparate par exemple comptons de
bonnières-sur-seine regroupe soixante
neuf communes nos repas elle quitte son
canton composé de coignières elancourt
et la verrière la commune
saint-quentinoise rejoint le canton
alors appelé de chevreuse avec 14 autres
communes maurepas et temps là la plus
grande ville le canton de chevreuse
prend le nom de maurepas il y à aussi
celui de montigny le bretonneux qui est
composé de deux communes montini et
guyancourt et le cas le plus particulier
c'est celui de la ville de versailles
puisqu'elle est coupée en deux le canton
versailles ne regroupe qu'une partie de
la cité royale et représente 65 mille
habitants celui de versailles 2 et
l'addition 2,5 ville le buc jouy en
josas les loges en josas viroflay et
vélizy villacoublay
et bien sûr la deuxième partie de verre
lire